You might think that taking actual people
out of a movie means taking the mistakes and
human error out with them.
But anyone paying close attention to modern
animated films knows that even the smallest
mistakes seem hilarious considering someone
made them one frame at a time.
And the bigger the mistake, the better it
is to search for.
Here are 20 Massive Mistakes in Animated Movies.
Zootopia
The animals may have evolved to walk and talk,
but math is still a problem.
Predators make up just 10% of the population,
but assistant mayor Bellwether later claims
that they're outnumbered 10 to 1.
Hopefully kids didn't take that as a math
class, since 10% means a ratio of 9 to 1,
not 10.
No older fan of Zootopia can forget the cameo
from actor Tommy Chong playing the mellow
Yax, one of the city's "Naturalists" - the
word the writers were looking for was actually
"Naturists" another words for nudists.
The Lion King
The age of hand-drawn animation may be all
but over for Disney, but some awesome mistakes
remain thanks to one animator.
Look closely when Mufasa is filling Simba
in on the kingdom, and you'll notice the label
"45" appearing on screen for two frame.
And you'll wonder how you never caught it
before.
Reference
Beauty and The Beast
Nobody fights like Gaston - or talks like
him.
His lips don't match his words in his final
fight with Beast, since his line - "Belle
is Mine" - was originally "Time to Die."
Softening the tone makes sense, but the original
animation was left behind.
The Good Dinosaur
The movie may be set in an alternate history,
one where the asteroid that killed off the
dinosaurs 65 million years ago passed by completely.
One problem though: the hero Apatosaur and
his family went extinct over 50 million years
before the asteroid ever struck.
Wreck-it Ralph
It isn't an animation glitch or error that
gives Wreck-it Ralph its funniest mistake,
but time itself.
Think about it: did you ever notice that Ralph
makes a jump into Hero's Duty as the arcade
opens, only for it to close just minutes later?
Either time passes faster in the game, or
it's an editing shortcut audiences aren't
supposed to catch.
The animators went to serious lengths to fill
the movie with video game cameos and details,
but a few mistakes slipped through as a result.
The sign at Game Central Station clearly says
that "Burger Time" is Now Playing - but nobody
told the star chef, serving pie to Q*bert
and his friends.
Despicable Me
The devil is in the details, especially in
animated films.
When Gru first reveals the stolen jumbotron
from Madison Square Gardens, the animators
added in some missing bulbs for character
- missing bulbs that somehow scroll along
with the words - it should have been one or
the other.
The movie's villain, Vector gets what's coming
to him eventually, but he should have gotten
his even sooner.
When he idiotically shrinks his sink and toilet,
his bathroom should have been a disaster of
spraying pipes - apparently, his toilet doesn't
even need plumbing, but it's a bad lesson
to teach troublemaking kids, either way.
Aladdin
The animators took the time to make sure all
the writing in the film was Arabic, but when
scrolls are read, or Genie takes an order
while in the form of a waiter the writing
is written and read left to right, like English.
But Arabis is read right to left.
As part of the romance between Aladdin and
Jasmine, the pair enjoy a Chinese fireworks
show in every color of the rainbow.
But colored fireworks are a more modern invention,
so the fireworks would only have been yellow
or white prior to 1850 - which the movie most
definitely is.
The Little Mermaid
Endings don't get much happier than this one,
with Ariel and Eric sailing off into the distance,
married, and treated to a rainbow.
But dark magic might still be at work - the
rainbow is reversed, making it one truly weird
mistake.
Finding Nemo
Sure, fish can't talk.
But you'll have to ignore science and physics,
not just marine biology when the final scene
of Finding Nemo comes, showing the escaped
fish each in their own bags of water - magically
defying physics, keeping their bags full of
water floating above the surface, instead
of sinking to match the height.
Monsters, Inc
The billions of hairs covering the monster
stars meant hours to render a single frame.
Luckily, some old fashioned mistakes slipped
through too, like the Pixar artist who forgot
the "i before e" rule when it came to the
word "yield" in Mike's file - TWICE.
A misspelled word is one thing, but how about
the biggest plot hole Pixar's ever seen?
Boo's laughter is so powerful, it overloads
entire city blocks when she really gets giggling...
that is, until she spends the rest of the
movie laughing with absolutely no effect on
the city around her.
Shrek
Kids now know that ogres aren't monsters to
be feared... well, not until they catch the
mosts disturbing animation glitch in the entire
Shrek series, when the hero's eyeball decides
to peek through his own eyelid.
It's still giving us nightmares all these
years later.
The plot holes get even bigger when it comes
to the movie's villain, Farquaad, who sets
the movie in motion because he needs a princess
to marry, so he can become king.
He chooses Fiona over Snow White, but Cinderella
is also offered up as a candidate... which
doesn't make much sense, since she married
a prince, she wasn't close to a princess before.
Frozen
As much as we'd like to believe that the famous
"Let it Go" musical number is perfect, one
of the strangest, most debated mistakes can
be found in the scene.
Watch as Elsa pulls her braided hair from
behind her shoulder to the front - until it
magically travels through her shoulder, already
in front ahead of time.
Don't be surprised if you don't catch it the
first time, but trust us, it doesn't add up.
Toy Story
It may be Pixar's first movie mistake, and
it's impossible to miss for any parent who's
used a baby monitor to keep a close ear on
a sleeping baby.
When the army men first set out to see what
new toys Andy's gotten for his birthday, they're
carrying the handheld unit - which only plays
audio.
They use the monitor as a walkie-talkie, and
Woody's base unit should let him send messages,
but the actual device wouldn't make much sense
if it send sound both ways.
Tangled
W/hen your lead character has hair longer
than a football field, some mistakes are
to be expected.
But it's obvious the animators wasted no time
in deciding what they could and couldn't actually
show: the second Rapunzel leaves her tower,
her hair ceases to exist.
It's understandable, but still a shame since
it's impossible to miss on repeat viewings.
Those are the animated movie mistakes we love
to watch out for, but what are yours?
Make sure you let us know in the comments,
and remember to subscribe for more videos
like this one.